♪♪
Nick Mohammed:
I remember Jason, before we
filmed season two, said
"it opens and closes on Nate’s
eyes”, and I was like ooh, what
does that mean?
Rupert’s just bought West Ham
United!
No!
At the end of season two,
there’s a bit of a battleground
forming between
Richmond and West Ham and that
battleground is the pitch!
What Nate did, um, no one could
have seen coming.
And, it feels like a huge
betrayal.
Brett Goldstein:
I just felt sorry for him, like
I was heartbroken for him at the
end of season two.
Ted was always really good to
him, took him under his wing.
Like, you know, stepped him up.
You made me feel like I was the
most important person in the
whole world.
I love it!
Nate:
And then, you abandoned me.
Nate the betrayer, Nate the son
figure, I think Ted is all those
things.
Jason Sudeikis:
I think we’re all, all those
things.
It's a really bold move by the
writers to take a character they
deliberately
got everyone to root for and
then just take it away.
It’s always good to keep people
on their toes, isn't it?
Well, hey, next season
should be fun, right?
(Whistle blows)
(Crowd noise)
Two months have passed since
season two
and these characters are shaking
everything up.
Reporter:
Regarding your old team AFC
Richmond,
any idea why everyone is
expecting them to finish
twentieth this season?
Probably because there’s no
twenty-first.
(Reporters laugh)
We have to rebuild a family
because a family was broken.
If the team is a metaphor for a
society at large or a family,
Jason Sudeikis:
we wanted to see how this family
dealt with it.
Did you hear what Nathan was
saying about you?
Yes, ma’am.
And are you planning on
addressing that?
No, ma’am.
I don’t think Rebecca can quite
believe that of all
the people that Nathan has gone
to, it’s F'ing Rupert.
There he is, the Wonder Kid
himself.
Rather than proving his worth to
the likes of Ted, who’s
obviously
Nick Mohammed:
a force for good, he’s proving
it to Rupert who’s a force for bad.
Nathan Shelley, you are a
killer.
Good morning Viet—
(All)
Ted!
At the beginning, Ted will feel
a bit beholden to
a flippant promise he made at
the end of season one to, uh,
win the whole thing.
Woah! Did I really say that?
Yes, you did! Over there before
you blasted half a liter of
Pellegrino in my face.
Oh, right.
-Wait, what happened?
Let’s go!
I think Ted has the opportunity
this season to make things
better.
What do you think if
we signed Zava?
Ah!
-Oh!
Second question.
Who is Zava?
Zava is this once in a
generation footballer.
Am I to assume that you’re going
to pursue a notoriously
mercurial player
Trent Crimm:
you can’t afford simply because
your ex-husband wants him?
Yes.
Love that.
People are going to see in these
characters the growth
that they’ve always wanted to
see from season one.
What are you doing?
I was going to hug you!
Well, you came at me too fast!
It's really interesting to watch
the team grow.
Toheeb Jimoh:
Ultimately, that’s the story of
Ted Lasso, isn’t it?
You are it. You are enough.
Ted:
Expectations for us are as low
as a rattlesnake’s belly button,
but hey we got thirty-eight
chances to prove all them folks
wrong though, right?
It will be as fantastic as the
show has been, if not more so.
How is it possible?
Sport,
Trent Crimm:
it’s quite the metaphor.
♪♪
It also makes for a
heck of a nickname.
♪♪